no one was going natural yet so this was
as good as it could be and i was like
i guess this is what my hair looks like
in adulthood i'm like i was ugly for no
reason
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who deeply believes that if
she could just
meet adam brody he would love her elise
morales and
with us today we have such a funny
friend
she's a comedian an actress an author a
youtuber a podcaster and
co-host of what a day on crooked media
but before
all of that she was a graduate of boone
county high school in
[Music]
hey everybody uh so happy to be here
i i similarly thought that seth cohen
should be my my husband so i feel
like i we we've he's come up on the
podcast before because
of how much he's he touched so many
teenagers lives with that role
but i could go off about him forever um
boone county high school what
mascot are we working with okay so boone
county high school uh in my time there
was the rebels um but not like rebel
without a cause rebels like the
confederate general
yeah and i was in that sweet spot after
they were like we're gonna you know
people don't love the confederate flag
being
the literal flag that our mascot's
carrying so we're going to make it like
light blue and dark blue instead of
red and blue and i'm like right it's
still a confederate flag
he's from texas he's texas he's just a
guy from texas
hanging out in kentucky he's like yeah
our mascot is a guy from texas exactly
yeah and
that was like there was absolutely
suspension of disbelief
i would say from everybody those you
know just like it's not racist like it's
pretty racist
i don't think it's the thing we can
debate has it changed now
yes and so this is actually like it's
kind of a bummer for
the podcast it's so much fun but it
changed to
they're still the rebels technically but
mr rebel who is this general
no longer exists and here is my belief
as to why
it no longer exists um because i had
called i'm like you guys should change
it to the boone county biscuits like
it's a southern heritage thing that's
great
everybody loves a biscuit it's funny
right i'd buy that field who's not gonna
love that
when a little biscuit comes out yeah and
i'm like oh when we beat like a team
that's like the falcons
like yeah the biscuits beating the
falcons is kind of a big deal
so you know i i had all of this you know
energy behind
changing this mascot forever since i
went to school there
and they never wanted to do it and there
were all of these excuses for why not
and then that charlottesville rally that
uh killed heather hayer
well the man who was driving that car is
from
like 10 minutes away from the high
school and went to another school in the
area
and so there was a very quick and quiet
sort of
bait and switch of like what mascot no
no no no no
we he would have never gotten any sort
of the south will rise again vibes from
us and i'm like uh
pretty sorry i love this idea of you
coming back home and being like where's
mr rebel and everyone just being like
yeah i haven't heard that no not
exactly
what happened to the guy it was on
everybody's shirts and [ __ ]
yeah like i still have some weird ugly
clothes
that say bchs from my tenure here and
now you go into your drawer and they
don't have anything on the shirt
it's all gone it's like the man they're
all getting away
they it was a really expensive uh it was
a very expensive ruse i mean
it was also kind of wild is like this
all happened
sort of at the same time that our local
zoo which is the cincinnati zoo was
doing their
um marketing campaign to stop people
from talking about harambe
so much so
what were your activities
at that time uh what extracurriculars
etc
fully so i would say that you know
babysitting my nephew was a big part of
my high school experience so
where other teens might have cool
pictures on the weekend drinking and or
i don't know reading the bible i
had just like photos of me with like a
baby and people would just think it was
my baby because it was kentucky and
they're backwards they're like oh you're
a teen you're a black girl
you're 13. so that must be your
two-year-old like what are you talking
about
y'all are crazy this is my cousin yeah
i'm like this is literally not my
child like i'm a baby i'm the baby and
so
that was a chunk of it but as far as
extracurriculars go i was like
super involved uh i would say before and
after his like
first and second year of life and so i
did choir that was in concert choir we
had like a show choir
which was the the cool football guys and
the hot girls who like were cheerleaders
not really like they were lip-syncing
but they would dance and like everyone
cared to see them okay that is not what
our show choir did
at all our show were weird old
like like gowns and they were
they just were like the fancier like you
had to audition to be in show choir but
they didn't
oh wow see we had auditions for all our
choirs we had three
and so show choir was like you know
you're cool and you're not really
singing
so like you don't have to be vulnerable
at any point this was like glee
for the show like they were okay it was
like fully like yeah like they and they
had like cute outfits and the girls
could like twirl and they would get
picked up and i'm like oh
wow and then they had girls ensemble
which was like
the girls who could sing and dance
and then like no apparently men aren't
allowed to have their own self
it was just like girls
[Laughter]
i'm like could it be girls gays and days
ensemble like could it at least be like
broader
could just make it the ensemble at that
point like
what's the benefit if they're at least
actually singing it is
choir and then i was in the lowest rung
you know i would say on the like um
hierarchy of cool kids
which was concert choir which was also
all women
and we did sing there was no dancing and
luckily the year that i started doing it
we they had gotten rid of the sort of
like matronly gowns and like you know
awkward terrible songs and so like they
were trying to get hipper so we had like
kind of cute like britney spears-esque
outfits but we were mostly standing
there
by britney spears-esque like oops i did
it
like okay yeah i should probably
quantify that
um i would i would say it was cut
the closest um iteration would be her
outfit in the crazy music video where
it's like the green top
and the pants there wasn't midriff
because like
you know teens look like everything
those pictures are forever so i think
they were just like
it'll touch the pants um and then when
we were like trying them on they were
all they were literally the green satin
top and then like black velvet pants and
then
it was like a silver white top and then
black
yeah i feel like jessica
simpson rocked this type of a million
percent
yes and of course you know the black
bottoms were flares like
yes yeah and no uniform shoes like
people were looking like everything up
there and we also always had a prop like
i think that the first concert we had we
had like a cowboy hat and i'm like the
only black person in the choir
so the photo is just like yeah like no
it's like this school is definitely a
mixed experience for me for sure
fully fully and i'm like oh wow this is
a disaster
and then yeah like why did we have to
sing country music and then also like
country ballads that were very old
there was a song called grandpa that i
was like i don't this isn't for me
um was it about loving your grandpa it
was like grandpa tell me about the good
old days like
like i was like what good day
who's grandpa we asking yeah yeah tell
me more about this grandpa
and his history yeah amen
yeah everything was sketch and then and
for christmas
we had uh we had santa hats which is
funny because it's like there was never
even
a little bit of ambiguity about holidays
it was just like christian holidays it's
kentucky
that's interesting like i think about
that because i remember
i did my like very early years when i
was a little kid in
la my parents like got married and moved
out there
and i remember even in public school
in l.a we had overt christmas
play christmas stuff fully
like full which i don't think is
happening
in public schools in la now because i
my first role that i ever played was in
our christmas play which was
um about an elf named alphys who was
just like
elvis and everyone was uh rude to him
and i said alphys get on out of here
i love that for you i think my first
role in
like a school production would have been
like third grade it was a speaking role
but it was like again like one line i do
not remember the line
um but uh the play was called the mice
of mozart
and so it was a lot of songs about these
mice that lived in like the floorboards
uh and so our outfits were giant black
trash bags
with like a little bit of lipstick on
our nose and like black lines and we're
just like we are the mice
and we'd all go up to the microphone one
at a time as if that's how a play is
supposed to work
and say our line and then step back and
like that yeah
that is how plays were in elementary
school you just walked up
said your line wearing a paper costume
and then just kind of went back
exactly and i'm like we did it that was
the whole play the rest of it it's just
like you looking around like we're in
plastic bags like it's hot
just like me just like airing it out on
stage so were you
a we're talking about extracurriculars
were you a theater kid
oh fully i was in speech and drama so it
was sort of like
you know there was the the fall i think
it's only actually a spring play
that i auditioned for and did not get
um and also like kind of grateful
because
the place that they chose again it's
kentucky we're always just like
whatever the budget you know like we
have the right to perform this at our
school like we i remember they did clue
the musical
which like i'm not sure if you know that
this is a thing
i did not know it famously um i will say
that
my high school did an unauthorized stage
production of the clue
movie that i would oh i love that
[Laughter]
that and that's the thing it's like i
loved clue the movie
you know growing up so i was like this
is gonna be just like it and then like i
started hearing the music because my
best friend was like
this girl who was a grade below me but
like
one of those girls was just like so hot
in high school like she could have been
and just like every boy in the school's
like who is that and so
of course she got to be in the play and
she played a french maid
you know like as in the movie and i just
sing a song that was like my life is a
bowl of cherries
and it was like a very like seductive i
was like this is
messed up and like all the weird gross
teachers were like yeah i like that
song i'm like of course you do um but
yeah so i was like a person who's like
painting the background because i just
wanted to hang out
but speech and drama like you know we
called it forensics
i think some places still call it that
that was my jam that was like my
my people so was that like um
like what makes it speech and drama
versus drama like were you doing like
debate
and stuff in there yeah like it was like
this big umbrella of like
weekend events of you know they had
congress so it's like you would present
your bill and then the congress would
vote on it and then you could win an
award and i'm like i hate this like
do not like this one i tried it for like
a week and i'm like this is boring
everybody here's dumb i don't like any
of your resolutions like
we need to protect like some salmon in
like some very small creek in their like
local kentucky town and i'm like
we're not saying yes to that if this is
a real congress
this should be handled somewhere else
how dare you bring this to us when we've
got stuff on our plate
the iraq war is raging sir totally
literally i'm like this is unimportant
you know when you're talking about fish
i'm just hearing that you think they're
ugly i don't care about the mercury
go to kroger and get over it so that was
definitely a big part of it um
but we did like improv so we had like it
was a short form improv
like you know here's a session you get a
few minutes to like literally plot the
scene and then perform it
yeah and then like you know
extemporaneous speaking oratory where
you're writing these eight minutes sort
of speeches
declaration where you're performing
these eight to ten minute speeches
um and then a bunch of other like
dramatic interpretation
i can't believe i'm remembering i don't
think this is kind of
like this is so so what like form did
this take in your life like a class at
school and then stuff
after school as well totally
fully yes and like i would say that
that's uh
maybe the unique experience i had at
least senior year
where i took classes that were both
semesters so it's like we had four
quarters a day
is how we did the classes they're long
ass classes and usually you'd have eight
in a year i had four
the whole year and it was like choir for
the big first block
and then the second block i think was uh
ap psychology
and then it was um you know then i had
yearbook which is just like
[ __ ] around taking pictures of people
and going on like trips with the band
on the weekend be like taking pictures
of them competing
and like i didn't know how to use the
cameras at all so like all the pictures
were just like black
were you able to like get yourself and
your friends in the yearbook more though
yes and that is the thing that i like
remember like when i look back i'm like
i'm not friends with any of these people
now but like i look at it i'm like
literally i took all the phones
and i was like the whole school was
seven students that's what i needed
like i i needed someone on yearbook
there's one like good picture well it's
a good picture of me that it's a funny
picture of me walking down the hall
of my high school with my best friend
and i'm wearing
a children's spider-man
t-shirt and a like full studded belt
i'm like ready yeah like you're like i
look good today
they better take the pig oh boot cut
jeans i know
i i knew that i looked amazing
in that [ __ ] yes you were like this is
the one i had like several shirts like
that they were from
i think it was maybe delia's or like
whatever the store was at the time the
cheapest store we could get like a
t-shirt for five bucks and it was like
literally made out of like flammable
materials
and killed me i would look at that
catalog
so much and i would always be like mom
please buy me stuff from the daily's
catalog and she would be like
no yeah yeah i mean that was the thing
it was like i remember when i would
babysit i think the most money i ever
got a week it was like 40 bucks and i
was like we're going ham
i spent the whole day like incrementally
spending like 1.50
at every store and i remember i got this
t-shirt that was brown
that had and then it had like an outline
of scooby-doo or something and i was
like this is cool
this is what the cool girls wear because
there's like some other i don't know hot
actual teen that like people cared about
who had the same shirt but she had the
pink one with the pink panther on it and
i was like
i'll wear the brown one i'm like no one
is looking at my brown t-shirt
but that was like did you live in that
like pop punk
aesthetic world because that was like a
big deal is like
i'm going to be into kids stuff and i'm
totally you sure with
kids stuff on it which totally i think
our generation is actually still doing
that
so yeah like we like i think you know
what's funny here's my dumb theory about
this is that uh
maybe it's really sound but i'm like i
think because the internet became
so pervasive as we were like you know
growing up
it was the first time that nostalgia was
something that you could actually like
bank on where it's like oh my gosh i can
look up a video
of like this commercial or like talk to
people online like do you remember
this game from this stupid class it was
jazz jackrabbit and people are like yes
yeah
like it's or hearing a recording of the
aol
sound which i would like to never have
heard again like i'm never gonna use
dial up to like hear that again but
totally
you're so yeah you're so right what do
you do you remember what your like early
websites were that you used back in the
day
yeah i'm not super proud so i think i
remember like
i don't know if this is a real place
there's something called like quizilla
maybe or like it's
kind of like an early survey monkey so
you just like ask a dumb question be
like okay guys fill it out um
and so i would build like little like
geo sites or geo cities i don't even
know how you say it
it would just be like dumb little
surveys and i'd be like one person
answered wow like
people are visiting my website
i'm bill gates
[Laughter]
so yeah i felt really great about that
but i would say high school for me was
so
live journal it was like every day after
school i'm like i have to see
who in my friend group is posting there
was always like somebody throwing shade
at someone and i'd be like what what is
this a cryptic drama
who are they talking about and then like
they're bad poetry and i'm like that was
so good ali like everything was always
the biggest deal
this i was also on live journal not
zanga me and my friend group were all
lives journal
and yeah i remember i would like write
like
well i really think that lainey was
being a [ __ ] today and then she would
be like why did you say that and i'm
like that's my live journal i can say
whatever i want
totally and i also just i think it's
like i learned how to be
more uh less um overt with what i was
talking about only because i was like oh
[ __ ] people are really starting to
realize
i'm talking [ __ ] here so it would just
be like code names for people and they
would still figure it out and then like
confront me at my locker like
akilah that was really hurtful what you
said about aubrey yesterday
and i'm like well i said it yeah and
it's also called the internet police
there was so many places where you could
start shady drama like your aim
profile huge major huge place to start
drama
depending on what like did your friend
group
like you would copy paste if someone
would said something funny
you would put it in your profile yes
like a funny thing they said in
conversation and like if you could get
in someone's profile that's like
honestly sweeter than a retweet fully
yeah it's like
because it's so important and also like
the away messages were just up longer
and like you know it's that thing where
your own aim and you're like everyone's
on here like even the people i'm not
friends with we exchange names at some
point
so like they could just read the away
mess and be like oh akilah had a pretty
good one at
drama class oh well i just uh
saw so-and-so's profile and
pretty funny dig yes and i always loved
like
when i would have a crush on a boy i'd
have that notification sound on where it
was like the door creaking open like
and i'm like oh my god run from across
the room
remember any crushes screen names and i
ask because
i remember that the boy who i had that
notification
on for the longest his screen name was
dj school ditcher
oh my god i'm obsessed with that being
the screen name
you know what's so funny i don't
i don't remember that's like i'm i know
who i talked to the most
and a lot of them were their actual
names right but then there were always
like
one more that is unique and he spelled
it like all up and down letters
and stuff oh yeah case and uppercase
yeah and you have like the little wiggly
line in it and you're like okay
yeah and he had you know those little
like remember they were like little
buddy icons
he had one circles that were like [ __ ]
or something like he had like a
like an edgy one and i was like yeah uh
kiss me kiss me now you're like you
relate to me you understand the
importance of upkeep
on this site you get it you're not just
willy-nilly with it all right you're
intentional with your page and i i felt
that i mean
yeah there were a lot of i feel like the
boys in my town were incredibly
unoriginal
but the um the girls were always like so
good like my best friend's last name in
high school was like miller
and she's still my best friend she's
like my forever friend and i remember
hers was like it's miller time
and then like the birth year whatever it
is like 88 whatever and i was just
remembering like that's so fly like
there's nothing for hughes but
you know what uh do you remember your
screen name
oh yeah i was um kiwi rabbit through one
okay very dumb it was like
it was like a childhood nickname and
then the one was just like i'm from the
internet
i know we can put a number here and i'm
like there's not going to be a kiwi
rabbit fruit too
punk rock show 5-1-5
oh my god yes i just i loved it
oh i just i remember days and days and
like late nights when i won't be like
what are you doing like
my mom's online all the time now and
she's like keyboard warrior for facebook
just like you're wrong and i'm like
those people aren't
real but like at the time she's like i
don't get what you're doing and i'm like
my whole life is this
my whole life mom i'm bearing my soul to
the world
exactly i'm figuring out how to get boys
to like me
were you a writer at this time
because like i know you know you've
written a book you
write your material all of this stuff
like were you
what was your relationship with like
because i couldn't see you being like a
fiction press girl
or like ooh girl okay yeah here's the
thing not really and like i think that
that's one of the
i don't yeah i mean you know maybe i
could unpack this as a therapist but
i i don't remember liking reading in
high school
just because the books that were always
chosen for classes i'm like i don't care
about holding coffee
it doesn't matter to me even a little
like heart of darkness i get what you're
doing yeah i don't have to write an
essay it doesn't matter that much to me
maybe
you know um yeah like the idea that you
have a forced essay on something you
don't care about
is such a cool thing that i'm like you
know i might have written more if i gave
a [ __ ] about any of this stuff
right i had one say in any of it it is
crazy to think about the fact of being
like
like the skill of having to write an
essay about something you
don't care about at all
at all because as an adult if you're
writing an essay
you care about the things yeah right
like unless you are like it's your first
day at a job and they're like you're
gonna write about garbage you don't care
also though like you would work at a
publication that cares about what you
care about like
you'd at least try to i just feel like
it's so you know in my professional
working at different digital media sites
it was always because they like
saw what i like to write about so it was
weird that like back then i'm like i had
no clue what i liked writing about it
was mostly just like
a messages and uh you know little dumb
like oh i'll fill out this quiz about
who i am and then like send them the
link
it was all very narcissistic it was pre
buzzfeed uh buzzfeed like it was
you know i'm going to figure out who i
am by virtue of dumb quizzes on the
internet i'm like i
am um the girl character from looney
tunes
like this is a lot of that all of my
identity i'm hermione
yes breaking news
i'm the girl in this there's the girl
i'm every woman and that's not what the
song is about but it'd be hilarious it
was like there's only one in each thing
so i must be
okay when you were in this um what was
it called drum
speech and drama yeah forensics okay
what forensics were you like
did you have a particular thing that was
like your sport
of it fully fully i had two it was
declamation which is like the 10 minutes
uh it was like a 10 8 to 10 minute
speech that um
someone else had written so it's like
they it has been read out loud before at
some point in history and it can be
anybody at any kind of level
um and so i had one that was like about
racism which i'm like ahead of the time
but it was just like stop stereotyping
people the media needs to reflect us
whatever
and so i was just like i remember i mean
you would practice all the time after
school and like have people be like
at this point you should walk to your
next point and so i just remember it was
like
you know it to me it was like beyonce's
homecoming it's just like
all right you're up but i like get up
from the desk in my like very nice
pinstripe suit
and like turn around and be like okay
like let's do this
and then just like perform the hell out
of it and i won
a lot like it was and you know you want
your whole school to win it's like a
bunch of different tournaments and then
it's kind of the olympics i guess yeah
we all do different stuff but you want
team usa
anymore i don't know but like at the
point at that point we totally did
yes and so i was super into that and
then um
improv duo was like i mean
there were like stakes for that because
there were people at every school who
were just like the best and so i didn't
always win that one like me and my
partner
didn't always win but we won comedy
with the two of you like yeah with a
scene or something
fully yeah like they'd be like here's a
suggestion or like a situation
like a mother and daughter are talking
about this and it has to be like comedic
and i'm like okay so then we like have
three minutes to like turn our backs and
be like
okay so like here are the plot points
and then like you know you'll just like
this will be the part where we turn but
like all the rest of it in here will be
the
the movement the touching the discussion
the scene
and i just remember being like i mean
i'd never seen anything like it and also
like it's not like ucb
you know like i took those classes i'm
like oh that's way more in depth like
first of all you're not getting a whole
like
the mom comes in at five o'clock to say
like you know you don't get a whole damn
situation yeah
yeah but it was just like this thing of
like you have to be so clever and you
also have to be so aware of like what
the audience is experiencing while
you're performing
and so it's like if it's boring wrap it
up or try something else but you have
like five minutes to do this uh
this the scene and so basically the
tournaments would always go three
rounds no one cares but it was three
rounds
and uh and then a final so it was like
four total if you made it to the finals
and you would either have like a comedic
um
first round a dramatic second round in
the comedic third round and then the
final round would be dramatic and you're
like you know for me i was always [ __ ]
because i'm like i'm gonna laugh i can't
cry on cue
no one's really teaching acting like
we're just teaching winning
the one with like a dramatic they would
be like
your father is leaving like totally yeah
like
somebody's father's leaving or like the
electricity got cut off for these poor
people
oh five minutes of that and i'm like a
lot of kids who
you know i mean it's kentucky a lot of
people have been poor so it's like they
can have very specific like
language they're using but it's also
like we're not fully developed humans
yet so it's
so like base level that i'm like how do
you even have a first place in this
yeah it's just kind of a lot to ask like
to blanket
ask a bunch of teenagers to go there
when you don't really know like what
their situation is right
right it seems kind of traumatizing and
like
it's not a skill set that's transferable
like if i was writing it
great i just wrote a great scene but
yeah it's just like
i this is what i would say if i got
evicted like
what is that for is that somebody taking
notes in the audience and they're going
to be like i'm going to say that when
i'm asking it
not a thing that you can use was your
friend group mostly coming from like
these
activities or like who was the crew
yeah my crew was definitely like a band
of misfits and i would say that like
it was always somebody like i had an
alliance in every class but i also like
for
for choir it was like me these twin
girls adam and amber and then like my
friend amanda it was like a tight tight
group
um and like we were we weren't
especially cool but we were like we
listen to different music and we're like
interesting and like
you know somebody's going to mcdonald's
before school they'll like bring it in
i feel like the choir will all just like
give him 1.50 for an egg mcmuffin
like it was like a and like you know we
would carpool and think so that was a
big chunk of it
and then i guess the other main class it
was like yeah it was like speech and
drama which also was
a period in the day it was like you
would have this hour and a half where we
would have more time to practice
and just like totally alliance is there
where there were like
i mean there was one guy in the class
who literally no one liked
and and like it's just like clearly just
we're like he's not
talented good smart interesting he
smells he sucks
and like at the time i'm like are we
being too hard on this person but i'm
like my instinct says no
i'll tell you elise i will tell you
i was on facebook the other day
and this person has gotten arrested for
like child pornography
we were all aware we were all kids and
we were like you're gross like
something about you is [ __ ] up and the
teacher i remember was always trying to
curb
like the bullying like we weren't trying
to get him to kill himself we're just
like don't
talk to us like the things you want to
talk about are weird you're gross
like we could just like the red flags
it's crazy there was a kid from my high
school named
zach who i knew because he was like
another alternative person around the
school
he wore like the big baggy hot topic
pants
oh yeah yeah and like anyone who wore
those pants like we were in kind of an
alliance even
yeah where you're like i see you i see
you you're gonna call [ __ ] on some
stuff yep
um after uh
school and just to paint the picture
this is like a tall gangly white kid um
he joined al shabab and
went to federal prison
whoa whoa i feel like every school
had like several people who had just
like what was that like it was like
everyone was like yo have you seen what
happened to zach
it is and that was crazy dude there was
a kid in my ap psych class who got
arrested by the fbi for like torrenting
stuff
and it was like a big day at the school
like did you see the swat people with
their fbi jackets
and i'm like for music so we were all
like
spooked i mean like fully like delete
limewire
wipe the computer i ran home you're like
really being worried that i was gonna
get arrested for pirating like a movie
or music or something i was like very
it didn't stop me from using limewire
and downloading yeah no i'm like i
[ __ ] up a lot of computers
i like got viruses viruses on my family
computer
yes yes fully i'm like my mom's like why
is it a brick again i'm like i guess
it's just a bad computer
i guess that's what it is maybe you're
going to weird websites
yeah like you should probably stop
visiting that stuff mom she's like i'm
never
we're just fighting about me gaslighting
her absolutely i've
never downloaded anything i don't know
mom yeah i'm like i don't think that we
can like i don't think our computer can
help i broke my family computer one time
because i downloaded so many of those
like
do you remember you could make little
like cartoon girls
hopefully
[Music]
i made so many that it broke the
computer
they're like we can't process all this
flash literally because
so many of them they
i love that i love that
to me that is like that is such a thing
that this next generation doesn't
understand like jinzy
will they're like what do you mean it
took an hour to load a photo what do you
mean your computer could break because
something moved too much
and i'm like yeah everything was really
delicate like there was also a fear of
technology because we're like oh my god
it's a billion dollars for a computer
like if this thing breaks i'm screwed
yeah and
it was like a complete mystery
every single all of us were derek
zoolander like as the monkey just being
like the files are in the computer
right right exactly
i had no clue how to work anything so
yeah that
that checks out for me all right let's
look through some of these photos that
we have
you know because we have some good ones
that i think encapsulate the myspace era
very well
actually uh so let's go to this first
one
oh goodness yeah here we go oh
that's that good stuff here's teen
aquila with the word
poop written on her point exclamation
point as well
this feels like a myspace user photo to
me
it was it was this would have been when
i was i would have just turned 16 here
so
like another thing that we don't have to
unpack but
i i skipped two grades to go to high
school so i was also
younger that whole time oh wow that's
okay that is actually
huge yeah it's a major like you know
there's a reason why i wasn't at all the
parties getting drunk and having like
maybe
bigger experiences but i was like here's
my party i'm gonna sneak in the back of
the
you know the band picture and go and
like for my
yearbook class and then i'll just like
sit next to a cute boy
and then we'll like cuddle and that'll
be my whole like romantic life right
uh so this was like uh this was my
freshman year of college
and of course everyone was like your my
space picture's got to get up like you
only get five or like
i think it's three at first so i was
like well that one's great
this but the thing that says myspace to
me as well is like the saturation on the
phone
put the saturation all the way up on my
photo
and do like highlights this yes
yes and the lip gloss is so bright also
i will like you know
my hair now you can't tell here i do
have big curly beautiful hair
but this stringy [ __ ] was like you know
no one was going natural yet so this was
as good as it could be and i was like
i guess this is what my hair looks like
and then in adulthood i'm like i was
ugly for no reason
i want to talk to somebody yeah
like i still straighten my hair on
occasion because i
have curly hair as well and
when i was in high school i was
straightening it
so i was killing death to death yeah i
remember it yelling like it would
crackle and i'm like oh yeah that's a
good stuff
like it is screaming for help i
straightened my hair wet
and it would go like yo
i've done it one time and i was like oh
it doesn't dry your hair
no it doesn't dry your hair it actually
just [ __ ] your hair
it just boils it off it just crunches it
um i don't know if you've ever
accidentally put a barbie in the dryer
which hopefully yeah like you're like oh
that hair is not hair
your hair the barbie and the dryer
quality that nobody's looking for
yeah yeah never featured in a magazine
as a thing we should all try i'll say
that
no and then i was like dying i was dying
my own hair at that time and bleaching
it myself
let's look at this next photo i've i
kept this one in because these you two
are cute
who's your friend oh my god so this is
also college it was like a
cool little party i mean it was also
like a small school so
we had dances we didn't have like house
parties and so it was like the first
dance it was like a mixer and
this is my roommate amy you guys have
like a cute
black and white aesthetic so you could
friendship with
yeah yeah you personally
yeah and also like the fact that we
chose to match at the dance
it's like in hindsight i'm like if
people thought we were dating that would
absolutely make sense to me
but the truth was i was just like you
always look so cool
i'm now in college and i have five
dollars for this t-shirt let's get like
matching outfits
i just wanted to be mary kate massey so
bad like super young in college were you
like a teenager in college
i was so this would have been like yeah
probably 16 years old and like
no one knew it even her as my roommate
it was like this like full
secret and it came out when i was
finally 18 and she was like
why didn't you just tell me and i'm like
because you wouldn't have treated me
like a friend like
this after school drama so
did you like live on campus the full
yeah you just like i was in the door
yeah yeah and no one knew like i
remember my first
actually the first day of college my
freshman year was my birthday
and so it was like okay everybody do a
fun fact about like who you were in
college or like or like
going around the room like introduce
yourself and i was like oh i'm achilla
and today's my birthday like how old are
you kayla and i'm like
i don't really want to say it like so
you're like 19 you're like a little bit
older i'm like yeah
just like fully just like okay and i
remember there were always like there
would always be
a little murmur of it that i was trying
to outrun and there was a girl on my
floor was like someone told me you're 16
is that true
like they don't let 60 year olds go to
college like i was talented that i'm
like oh another crisis averted like
i've been in montana
exactly thanks for stopping in you need
anything else like
tipped people off to your 16-ness
well i think it was literally like there
had to have been some sort of like paper
that was informing them
right like hey there's a there's a minor
so like if you're gonna get people
trouble for drinking
look for her and i was so afraid to get
in trouble that i didn't drink at all
like until sophomore year okay now
we have an iconic thing that you have
provided
which is a screenshot of your
myspace page this
is a beautiful relic
yeah i'm i'm i'm pretty sick i gotta say
like
this is actually a lot um so you're
do do do you want to walk us through
this page yeah
you know let's just start with the quote
i mean also like kind of amazing that it
just says aquila because i always had a
vanity name
and for the longest time it was diet
rockstar because that was the energy
drink i was drinking
i love that rockstar is fun but yeah
it's like a pretty cool name
and um so yeah the quote is your home
smelly later
based on the fresh prince which was not
on tv still i'm not
my space isn't though um and you know my
mood was imaginative
i said it was from in bufu kentucky
which is a phrase that i guess you know
anyone who's from the middle of nowhere
gets like bum [ __ ] egypt kentucky
sure um it looks like i i had some
notifications waiting for me but they're
on the other side it's like i don't know
what this box is it says achilles torn
about haircuts and extensions
i don't think at any point i was getting
my hair like professionally done
i'm like was i torn about other people's
yeah
maybe you just wanted to give off the
impression that maybe you would be
getting extensions you know what this
goes to show that tina keela knew that
that there was better hair in her feet
right there was no part of her that was
unaware of like
look this is a starting point this is
something i'm doing right now because
this is how it has to be exactly no one
else knows how to do my hair here and
we're just gonna look
like this and then you know there's this
blog section which like
uh i went to the disney college program
internship program in college so i would
have been 18 or 19 for those
so this is like definitely late myspace
where i'm still trying to be like
facebook's not as good as myspace it's
just a ripoff so i was spending more
time on myspace even though like
facebook obviously ultimately became
the yeah i remember trying to hold out
too and being like no
i'm not going to give up my myspace
right i was like why can't you
customize your facebook why does it have
to be white
right exactly why do you only get one
picture it's so lame that you can't
assault someone with a song the moment
they come on here right exactly and a
song
that you might not even remember is
there so you're scared every time you're
like oh my god why is bath water by no
doubt playing
yeah which was the song um again
i want you to want me the cover from 10
things i hate about you
for a while and then i also had dead
kennedys kill the poor
oh yo i love that i love that
yes i think at some point like maybe the
peak of me on my space was like
cobra starship songs you know like
whatever those songs are
it was like that was who i wanted to be
i was like these cool girls with their
swoop hair and a like a
external headband yes uh
i wanted the hair that like
you could people have like leopard print
and it was
like the bump like it was big on top and
then it became
really wispy and straight at the bottom
yes and like it would be like yeah it
would be like zebra stripes horizontally
so it'd be like a little fluffed and
like
blurred really horrible put like a
one little bow in there i wanted that oh
my god the tiniest bro
same i would like i remember saving
pictures of girls like that being like
i could just take this to any hair salon
and they're like what are you
asking me to do exactly i guess it is
just a style less of a
punch or anything like oh yeah
uh can you explain it um
right yeah like i needed to
muffin i need a muffin and then strings
strings and so then yeah oh a number of
blog posts here
uh i mean most seems to be from disney
we have another one that says baby hot
plant
baby hot pants slash we make video now
you know what this means i do and i am
like i should be ashamed and somehow i'm
not
uh if you look this up on youtube there
is just the oldest video you've ever
seen that's called baby hot pants
and it is a commercial for adults
wearing
uh like tiny toddler shorts on their
ankles
and then just like kind of kicking their
feet around but we like made a whole
song
and it was really good it was like
wherever i go people stop and they
stare they say where oh where can i get
myself a pair of the baby huffman
it was just a dumb sketch and then it
was like i don't know if it was like an
infomercial because then there were also
like
a bunch of different characters we had
they were like when i started wearing
baby
like it was just very dumb but we were
like we are sketch comedy geniuses and
the truth is
we were very like for our campus super
viral like
a thousand view video but it's like that
was all from the game that was
huge to get a thousand view video and
also like major i feel like
that was the time like comedy was rife
for stuff like baby hot pants
marcel the shell with shoes on yes oh
amen yes it was like
it was before the obama administration
maybe like a
in that you know that pocket it had to
have been i think
and it's just really wild to think like
oh well you know the world was crumbling
we were approaching a recession we were
also just like already broke in college
so no real sense of that
and just like oh let's use our resources
it's going to take 17 hours to upload
this one minute video
yes we're just going to do it and so
yeah
i do miss the old internet of like first
of all like video websites like going to
home star runner to see like what
happened every day videos were
or whatever i was huge into like brad
nealy he did wizard people dear
reader where he like talked over uh
harry potter and he also did he had a
viral video about george washington that
was like washington
washington six foot twenty [ __ ]
killing for fun
yeah yeah like there was like a it was a
peak
of like uh it was a lot of flash
animation that i was obsessed with like
there was something called tiny plaid
ninjas that i remember just like
knowing like the back of my hand and
like all of home star runner but
specifically teen girl squad
was like my sweet spot oh i loved team
girls
i still do it's like it's so ridiculous
how good those animations were i'm like
i don't i mean flash doesn't exist
anymore so they must have just recorded
and put it on youtube by now but like
man that was like a like a ritual it's
like i'm done with class for the day
it's four o'clock no one's ready for
dinner
let me go to home store see what the
voicemail is it was like a new team girl
squad i would be like
yeah i'd be like at everyone on amazon
uh i miss i i mean
i feel like i always say that i i'm
always like kids don't get that i
actually don't know that
i actually don't think yes and here's my
funniest book oh yeah exactly and like i
think that like they're also
more empowered to make things so it's
like we were so much more consumers
than i think that they have to be now
but my theory is
here it goes is that there were there's
probably versions of what we had now but
like
because there's so much stuff there's no
central like as
teenagers we all liked this like it'll
be just tick-tock dances not like a
dance
whereas perez was like you were on this
website you were like
and we all watched this and it was like
it's just this cultural across
the board like experience whereas now
i'm like there's just gonna be tiny
fractions of nostalgia in the future
and also maybe none because it's like
well there's always gonna be new stuff
and
who cares to talk about it yeah like
there are still some videos that
break through and everyone sees them but
it's more in like the
viral yeah whatever world
i mean there will be like front-facing
like characters and stuff that people do
that go super viral and stuff but i feel
like we grew up in this golden age of
like
weird flash animation videos
about crazy [ __ ]
yes totally and it was always like
you know there was such a i don't know
it was a much smaller
world in terms of like even tv shows so
it's like the references were all there
like if you're going to talk about lost
i know the main characters even if i'm
not like up to speed on the episode like
you just had to be aware of things um do
you remember
salad fingers yes and i remember being
freaked out by it and the people who
would show it to you i'd be like
i don't want to see this rusty spoon
[ __ ] like i get that you like it
i remember really i like vividly
remember the image of his weird
salad finger going on the rusty spoon
and i like i was like this isn't for me
i'm not the target demographic but
similarly
do you remember old greg oh yo i did
love old greg though
and now i like the roasting great
that's him that's old greg
that's old greg
[Laughter]
i i literally i have to go and stare
into the abyss
for seven hours akilah it's all good
i didn't know oh greg was hosting
wholesome tv
i thought he was in whatever that creek
or gross
lagoon no that
the delightful man who hosts for who is
old
if if nothing else from this podcast
episode i
just know that me for it like knowing
now that this was old greg
was enough it was enough all right
i uh let's look through the next
i think we've got a prom picture here
yeah woof honey
look at everybody know what first of all
let's just start with the obvious
shapewear didn't exist
there was no like pristine look so like
you know this is me
at a youthful teen skinny for me and i'm
like
it's pooching all over the place
everybody's belly button is fully
visible
so my hair looked so crazy at prom
[Music]
i remember i booked looks are always bad
yeah and like that's part of the charm
but we don't realize it at the time
and even now i'm like why am i so
ashamed also i'm hugging some girl that
i couldn't tell you like if she even
went to my high school like who is that
who is that but uh yeah
go with a boy where what was tina
akilah's dating situation
oh it was so bleak the truth is
i had no boyfriend and the darkest like
the saddest thing and like this is a
person i'm still friends with uh
this boy mickey i like my he had
he i don't know if he he had dated my
friend stephanie but like they were on
good terms and she was dating some
football player by that point
and so like he was like a sweet speech
and drama boy and so i was like look
i know you don't have somebody to go
with i don't have anybody to go with
why don't we just go as friends together
so we like you know we don't take
pictures or anything like i was already
like downplaying my value like you don't
even have to like tell people like let's
just go together
and he told me and i'm like my mom said
that she would pay for your tuxedo
and he was like i'm just not gonna go to
prom i go to prom
he goes and he's wearing a suit from
speech and drama not even a tuxedo no
todd like no bow tie
he just went alone wow and so i was like
you would rather not have someone to go
with and wear this [ __ ]
than [ __ ] date me and i was like that
is the
biggest rejection i mean even still i'm
like damn
yeah i feel like honestly
it you should be grateful to him because
that's the biggest
like that's yeah fully yeah like yeah
like actually yeah i'm like being
traumatized at that age it's like
no one can hurt my feelings that's why i
have this blind insane confidence where
i'm like
guys i'm gonna get what i want you know
why because like no one here is gonna
make
my feelings hurt anymore ever again
gonna shut like you're never gonna show
up at prom and
have them be there yes oh woof
i mean truly horrific also like cliff
notes on this look
um my sister bought the dress for me
which i thought was really nice
um but also my hair is doing a sort of
george washington shape and it's because
i didn't realize you had to get your
hair done the same day of prom so i did
it the night before
smashed it all down and then i'm like
this doesn't look like anything and i'm
like well
i have a curling iron and she just like
bumped the edges so it's like
real horrendous like wasn't better up
close
it's coming in at an interesting and a
real triangle situation
yeah she's been a real pickle a real
triangle
and it is funny because i feel the
aquila that i know
is an extremely stylish woman who always
has
like cool hair going on like she knows
what she's doing with her hair she knows
what she's doing with her style
but when you're a kid it's like nothing
no guidance this is a fancy
dress like right i'm like this seems
like it's in line with what the kids and
we're all wearing kitten heels i mean
just like
it's and also like look at there's so
little information in this photo but i'm
like look at this bland ass suburb like
i don't know whose house we were at
taking this photo i'm pretty sure my mom
was like
parked and was like all right i'll drop
you off like i didn't fit in the limo
with anybody it was so bad and i went
home at like
11 like it was just nothing and my
period came
and then the chocolate fountain they had
a chocolate fountain that problem which
nobody wanted
and it exploded onto my dress it was
like i poop on my front
but i did bond with like the coolest
girl in my school and she's like also
like out in l.a now and we still are
friends
but she was like the only left-leaning
human being in my high school
she also was like the best looking
person like one every
every single like everybody here wants
to kiss you
like she was just like that person and i
remember she was having a shitty night
her boyfriend was like cheating on her
in the bathroom or something i don't
know and her dress was this huge
pink puffy thing and so we were just
both seated because i'm like i'm
covered in chocolate she can't move
because the dress is too big
and we were just like sitting there and
like oh this is nice like we could just
talk about
how much this blows and it did it was
great
that was actually that brings me to one
final thing i wanted to ask you about
which is i mean obviously you work at
crooked now you host what a day you're
active
politically just in general with your
voice so
what was that like for you in high
school
were you as politically minded then as
you are
now and how did that play out with like
your peers yeah i mean i guess like
there are levels to this so it's like i
think i'm probably the most outspoken
i've ever been now just because like the
internet is so much broader
and also just like i'm not the first one
saying things so i'm not like tiptoeing
in like
hey guys just don't be racist to me okay
they're like i'm going to be racing
okay you know like it was a lot of fear
um yeah exactly
like yeah no it's fine like i'll go to
detention because you like told them
that i threw that french fry it wasn't
me i don't have french fries
like it's like i just think you're
racist like what you said like nothing
so i was like a little nervous but i
also think that like i was political in
very specific ways like
i was always anti-george w bush i knew
that that election was like a [ __ ]
theft and so when john kerry ran for
office like i had a shirt i was like
this is ridiculous like it's we
shouldn't be going to war
of course like i still agree with myself
i'm like thank you for being on the
right side of history
yeah but like yeah i remember just like
everybody was sort of dunking on me when
he didn't end up winning i'm like
great so you're going to go to war and
die
get grass idiot yeah okay yeah
like boone county kentucky like right
getting everybody for this [ __ ] war
exactly i mean like that's another thing
that i think about now living in l.a but
before living in new york is that like
you know i had lots of progressive
friends i still do but like there is
this like
you know small town poor rural you know
suburbanist sort of
community where i'm like a lot of people
died in the iraq war where i was from
like it wasn't rare and so i'm like why
are you all you and they're like cause
we're fighting for the country and i'm
like
have you ever thought about if you
wanted to live
like i feel like i there's a lot of
stuff that i would fight for if i wasn't
definitely gonna die
yeah if you could guarantee my survival
happy to go on out there but i'm like if
you
if i'm just gonna go and get like murked
i i would fight for something i care
like
i care about the country but i don't
think that this is it yeah it's all
bad and so i do remember like there was
some class where there was a question
about
um you know like i don't remember what
it was i said something about
george w bush and i like really like
stuck to my guns and it was like
akilah how can you say that and like all
the [ __ ] like sports guys be like no
that's my dad i'm sad now shut up aquila
and i remember
like that girl uh her name's tasha
courtney she's great follow her on
instagram i guess
whatever but um i just remember she like
yeah she like met me at the water
fountain like i was drinking at the
water fountain and i'm like oh god here
we go and she's like i heard what you
said
like someone told me what you said in ap
psychology i'm like yeah and she's like
i just want you to know like
i'd be your accomplice like i'm here
with you girl i'm like
you're the prettiest girl in the school
and everyone in the hallway is like
circling around
like what's the conversation it's just
her being like comrade
i was surely like i i loved that and
then that was literally her
like drawing the the fish the like
christian fish and like ancient times on
the ground in front of you
being like yeah i am a liberal yes
yes and like it's so funny to think
about like how like that was how small
the community was it was like
we we communicated through whispers at
the waterfall
like you couldn't possibly go against
the grain in northern virginia
it was really mixed like i remember like
it was just
equal like really and you're like it's a
proximity to
is or is it close to dc it is yeah so
it's like you have like that over county
so like like i could skip and go into dc
to see the panda
that's right there was like a lot there
was a very active young republicans and
a very active young democrats but i
remember being
shocked when george w bush won again
shocked beyond and learned nothing no
lesson from that
found myself shocked 2015 was pretty
ugly for me
yeah it was like truly just hello
darkness smile
like akilah you i mean you know maybe
this it was certainly now like a bigger
loss but god
like you know it's just such a painful
thing to be
involved in like politics it would be so
easy if we were stupid and didn't care
you know
yeah yeah i feel like that's like a
place for us to end it so
i am going to ask you our final question
of the pod
which is if you could talk to teen
akilah
what would you tell her um
i think i was a team that cried a lot
and so i would probably start with
kayla a lot of worst stuff is gonna
happen and she's just like start like
welling up it'll be like
but also you stay good looking
and only get better looking and you
don't live here
like the future isn't here and she's
like where is it of like new york and
los angeles
you're like am i a coastal elite i'm
like i guess
exactly like things are things are going
well you get what you want and
and she'll be like yes i won't be broke
forever and then she'll remember
chuck liberal what yes he's like what's
a blue tag
what is twitter come back
so many questions come back exactly is
this like a thing
is this a joke we look the same kind of
you just kind of like
round them
i stand by all of those messages i think
those are beautiful messages thank you
so much for doing the pod i feel like
of course forever about this yes
this is always my favorite show to do
like the truth is i think that like
you're you're just so funny this people
are like what is this part of the thing
but i think honestly
in the hellscape what a light to be able
to laugh for an hour about
the doofus i was in high school really
and for everyone listening at home i
hope you feel the same way and this has
been the roast of your teenage self
podcast
you